in CSS you first write what's called a
selector and this defines what elements
of the page a particular style will
apply to you can select an HTML tag and
that rule will apply to all tags on the
page and if for example you want to
apply style to all paragraphs on a page
you can do so by writing the following
another way to do so is to select
elements by class and this is what we
did in our previous example so if we
want to write a style that applies to
the class description we do so by typing
dot description and inside the brackets
you write the style in the form
attribute colon value so for example we
can say attribute color is value red you
can also combine selectors so for
example you can select all links that
are inside an element with the class
article there are links to the
instructor notes for more information on
this now earlier we said that red wasn't
really the best color but what if we
wanted to learn more about colors and
how to define them logically we could
say instead of typing red I might want
to type blue or black or any other color
but what if I want to get more specific
there's got to be a way to do that right
of course there is I mean CSS has a lot
of functionality and it's impossible and
unnecessary to go into every detail
right now and memorize all possible
attributes and values I mean you
probably fall asleep at your computer
right now and none of us want that
instead you should get comfortable
referencing the CSS documentation we've
included a link in the instructor notes
in exploring the page you'll see that
there are a lot of attributes that you
can use for example going back to our
color reference we can search for color
scrolling through the documentation
you'll find examples of different ways
you can define colors you can find the
color red we used before you could also
call RGB colors here you'll find the
color red example we used earlier you
could all
so call hexadecimal colors or even RGB
going back to the documentation let's do
a small exploration into font properties
search on the page for the font style
attribute then answer the following
question which of the following are
possible values for the font style
property is italic a possible value what
about bold or normal is that a possible
value what about standard also which
property would you use to make the text
look bold